of the new like gun owners you're seeing
like people that are coming to shop
recently who are they like where do they
look like what are they I mean you said
it was a lot of Latino stout their mom
is it a lot of gangsters is it a lot of
females what is it you know well at our
all-time fan at our shop we get we got a
lot of gangster gangster diff all kinds
I mean I've seen like dudes that are
borderline like white nationalists mmm
yeah straight up like straight up show
love it got all excited yeah just
straight like just black gangsters
yeah Bloods crib that kind of stuff and
and yeah they don't I mean a lot of
times they don't even hide it like I
what about Jews do you see any Jews in
there a few not too many I feel like I
feel like I don't know I feel like a lot
of Jewish supremacist now
like people are devout Judaism only type
of [ __ ] yeah scientists you know yeah
right I feel like I feel like they have
their own way of getting guns we sell
Jewish guns we got some like stuff from
Israel there which is kind of cool Wow
yeah Israel makes a lot of weapons yeah
it's a weapon belt over there hell yeah
hell yeah to technology and weapons man
yeah well they're surrounded by their
enemies you know yeah it's a hot area
it's a good area to have a weapon yeah
oh hell yeah so so so go ahead you're
seeing you've seen a lot of Latinas
you've seen a lot again is that a lot of
gangbangers it is a lot of step-mom I'm
not almost not a lot you get if you get
that occasionally it's just a lot of
just really random people man whether
it's like people my age you know just
first-time gun buyers 21 years old
single women for women with kids and
everything the fears about the pendant
like about the okay 100% they're there
they're there telling telling us like I
don't know what to get I don't know
anything about guns I don't even really
want to know anything about guns I just
want to get one that was me really yeah
kind of I mean I had I knew I wanted a
handgun I'll look through right some
guns and kind of picked out the one that
I wanted exactly but I don't think you
were there entirely out of out of fear
man they were a lot of people were there
really just like looking around and they
just kind of they just kind of were
freaking me out to be honest with you no
and is there an element where you have
to like if somebody's choose you you
determined that they have too much fear
is that can you still have to sell them
a gun I wouldn't say I have to but
there's a scary person to sell a gun to
you know I'm saying like yeah if I'm
coming from a place of like yeah just
complete fear then I could
I can make some poor choices you know a
hundred percent you don't want to
[ __ ] shoot a guy and he just had the
mail yeah I know for sure but that's
that's where it gets tricky because you
also don't want to deprave someone of
their second remember right especially
when there's a limited amount of gun
stories and it's hard for them to get in
I mean a lot of people were waiting for
five hours for service yeah and they
want to get a gun and despite the
reasons I mean I have feared that's not
necessarily a reason where I can take
away their constitutional right that's
what I see right so yeah so there's no
so there's nothing in it like where you
make any sort of like psychological like
mental health evaluation of them we have
the freedom to okay we can and like
another thing like by requirement if you
smell like marijuana I can't serve you
Wow liddie and I've had a to like I mean
man I have some stories of these
gangsters that come in all the time man
or just anyone any people it's not like
weed but just like usually people that
walk into a gun some real [ __ ] cholos
I mean they've written that they sit in
their infinity you know and they're
smoking up backwards yeah and they're
like they're in the parking lot and the
birds right now let's go buy guns now
first week yeah yeah what the [ __ ]
and do they a lot of times thinking able
to get it day of Oh almost people in not
most but a lot of people were getting
upset at us because they were like it's
a 10-day waiting period in California so
if you start the background check that
day right then ten days from now you can
come pick it up right right that's what
I'm going through right now it just got
extended - it just got a as of recent
they've been extended a little bit the
DOJ pretty much sent out a notification
to us that they're completely backed up
on background checks going through so
even after the 10-day waiting period the
background check might not have cleared
yet so we've had I mean this weekend
probably over 40 people come pick up
their guns and we had to deny them that
access to pick up their firearm even if
it was after their 10-day waiting period
just due to the fact that they cannot
the DOJ has not cleared their their
background check Wow
yeah it's just pending and I checked it
for you this is pick your pickup day
with yesterday yeah you're going through
the same thing if you came in yesterday
to get your firearms which it would have
been after the 10-day waiting period you
would not have been able to and now has
that ever happened in your line like in
your time of work no one I talked to
there has ever seen that ever and so
what do you attribute that to just the
sheer amount of people that are buying
guns in the United States and
California maybe it's good at least it's
like okay we have to run some sort of a
background check we're not just
filtering all these people through yeah
yeah I mean especially in California man
that that background check process is
California and there's other states to
do backgrounds there's a national
background check system right when you
fill out paperwork and that's what you
did right and that national background
check system doesn't necessarily mean a
10-day waiting period there's a lot of
other states where you can buy a day off
and take it home yeah California is one
of one of the only and not one of the
only but there's a few states that have
a waiting period day of you can buy oh
yeah yeah I mean Arizona Utah you go buy
it they are fill out the paperwork take
it home dude Arizona you know that they
take a driver's license picture when
you're like 19 years old and then you
have to get it done again for 50 years
[ __ ] imagine yeah I know guys like an
old man man he look at let me see your
ID it doesn't even look like a man like
his kids look at the grandkids man
that's funny good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes your life well
you could watch this one or watch this
one watch this one watch this one watch
this one